اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض معكم ابرز المستجدات وفي
العناوين
حصيله قتلى كارثه الزلزال في تركيا وسوريا
تتجاوز خمسه الاف وعمليه البحث عن ناجين
بين انقاض الاف المباني مستمره
فرق انقاذ دوليه تصل تركيا للمساعده في
جهود الاغاثه هو مزيد من الدول ترسل
مساعدات
رقعه حريق ميناء اسكن التركي تتسع بشكل
كبير واحتراق مئات حاويه البضائع
فرار ما لا يقل عن عشرين نزيلا بعضهم
ينتمي الى داعش من سجن في شمال غرب سوريا
بعد زلزال
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا البدايه من كارثه
الزلزال التي حلت بتركيا وسوريا وفي اخر
تحديثات لارقام الضحايا اعلنت اداره
الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه افاد ارتفاع عدد
قتل زلزال ضرب جنوبي البلاد الى ثلاثه
الاف وثلاثمائه
وعدد المصابين الى 20 الف واربعمائه
فيما اعلن المرصد السوري ارتفاع عدد قاتل
الزلزال في سوريا الى
1580 ويواصل عمال الانقاذ في تركيا وسوريا
عمليات البحث عن ناجين بين انقاض الاف
المباني التي انهارت جراء سلسله زلازل
عنيفه هزت البلدين الامم المتحده مشاهدينا
كانت حذرت من ان اعداد الضحايا مرشحه
للارتفاع بقوه بسبب وجود الاف المباني
المنهاره كليا او جزئيا بينما تتواصل جهود
الاغاثه الدوريه واحدثها اعلان العراق فتح
جسر جوي الى تركيا وسوريا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
معطيات حول الوضع في شمال سوريا مرحبا بك
وبساد المشاهدين اعداد ضحايا الزلزال في
عموم سوريا تم تحديثه الان وارتفع العدد
الى 1600 قتيل في مناطق النظام ومناطق
سيطرات
المعارضه في مناطق في مناطق سيطره
المعارضه 800 قتيله ايضا في مناطق
المعارضه 800 قتيل اي ان العدد الاجمالي
ارتفع الى 1600 شخص فقدوا حياتهم في
الزلزال الذي ضرب مساحات واسعه من البلاد
صباح يوم
امس ايضا يعني تم انقاذ حوالي 180 شخص في
عموم سوريا تم انتشالهم من تحت الالقاب
وتوجيههم الى المشافي في في مدن اللاذقيه
طرطوس حمى وحلب في جميع مناطق السيطره لا
تزال عمليات البحث من قبل الفرق الدفاع
المدني والبلديه والهيئات الصحيه والطبيه
مستمره رغم انها تعاني من ظروف غايه في
التعقيد اعداد كبيره من العائلات لا تزال
تحت الارقام جهود الفرق الاغاثيه وفرق
الانقاذ لم تصل الى اعداد كبيره من هذه
يعني
الولايات المهدمه على سبيل المثال مدينه
او بلده جنديرس التي تحطم فيها حوالي 84
مبنى جهود الانقاذ لم تشمل سوى 12 مبنى
هذا يعني ويقدم اشاره او دلاله على ان
اعداد الضحايا مرشح الى الارتفاع وربما
يتضاعف هذا العدد مع ما هي الموجوده على
الارض لاجراء عمليات البحث والانقاذ يعني
في مناطق المعارضه يختلف يختلف المشهد عنه
في مناطق النظام في الاولى
الدفاع منظمه الدفاع المدني الى جانب بعض
المدنيين المتطوعين وقطاع يعني قطاع
القطاع الخاص قدم اليات بينما في مناطق
النظام هناك هيئات اكثر تخصصيه يعني فرق
الانقاذ اكثر تخصصيه وتمتلك خبره اكبر
اضافه الى قطاعات من الجيش النظام هيئه
الصحه الهلال الاحمر
بعض من المنظمات الدوليه عبر افروعها في
دمشق اضافه الى مشاركه العشرات من الجنود
الروسي يقومون بازاله الانقاض امكانياتهم
ولو كانت ضعيفه لكنها تبقى افضل من مناطق
المعارضه التي تعاني من مشاكل كبيره
للغايه في ازاله الانقاذ والبحث عن ناجين
محتملين تحت هذه الانقاض طيب
ايضا يعني كيف قضى السوريون ليلتهم يوم
امس وانا هنا اتحدث عن ناجيني بطبيعه
الحال يعني الناجين من هذا الزلزال سوى
الذين خسروا منازلهم او الذين خرجوا من
المنازل اخذوا
ليلتهم لقضوا ليله رعب خارج المنازل بعضهم
يعني اخذ يعني السيارات كوسيله للنوم
والتدفئه
وبعضهم ذهبوا الى المناطق الريفيه
للجوع الى بعض الاقارب
بعضهم نزلوا من البنايات متعدده الادوار
ليسكنوا في منازل ويتشاركوها مع اخرين
منازل نحن نسميها هنا بالدول العربيه يعني
منازل من طابق واحد لاسيما وان الهزات
الارتداديه للزلزال ان لم تتوقف سلات هزات
يعني ثلاث ارتدادات منذ ليله امس وحتى
الان شهدتها مناطق حلب وادلب وبشكل جزئي
مدينه القامشلي هل من مساعدات وصلت الى
مناطق الشمال الغربي السوري سواء من داخل
بلاد او من خارجها جمعه يعني حتى الان
المساعدات اختصرت على طائرتين عسكريتين من
العراق تحمل سبعين طن من الموادئ لغاسيه
والطبيبيه والبطانيه وصلت الى مطار دمشق
الدولي على ان تلحقها شحنه بريه عبر البر
الحدود العراقيه السوريه تحمل عقود
التدفئه طائره ايرانيه ايضا تحمل مساعدات
هذا كل المساعدات التي وصلت الى عموم
سوريا حتى الان بينما اطرت التركي معبر
باب الهوى لا يزال لا يشهد اي
المساعده نعم
مشاهدينا الان نتابع هذه الصور المباشره
من منطقه غازي عنتاب في تركيا حيث يواصل
عمال انقاذ عمليات البحث عن ناجين بين
الانقاض وبين ركام هذه المباني التي نهارت
بسبب الزلزال الضخم والمدمر الذي ضرب جنوب
تركيا وشمال غرب سوريا يوم امس الحصيه
الاجماليه مشاهدينا لعدد القتلى في
البلدين تجاوز الخمسه الاف قتيل بعد هزات
ارضيه عنيفه ضربت مناطق قريبه من الحدود
التركيه السوريه بلغت قوتها سبع درجات
فاصله خمس درجات
وصبيحه هذا اليوم ايضا ضربت ضرب زلزال
مناطق في تركيا
ربما بلغت قوته سبعه سته درجات فاصله خمس
فرق الاغاثه تركيا احصت ايضا انهيار اكثر
من 5000 و600 مبنى في العديد من المدن
بينها مباني من طوابق عده تضم عائلات
كبيره
هناك مخارج ايضا مشاهدينا من ان يستمر عدد
القتلى في الارتفاع بهذه الوتيره حتى ان
منظمه الصحه العالميه قدرت ان قرابه 20
الف قطير ربما يكون قد سقطوا في هذه
الكارثه كما نشاهد المشاهدين هذه الصور
المباشره لعمليات الانقاذ في غازي عنتاب
التركيه واكثر من 5000 قتيل حتى الان في
سوريا جراء هذا الزلزال المدمر
بين نوع الحرب وبروده فصل الشتاء يعيش
السوريون شمال البلاد هذه الايام على وقع
هزات زلزال عنيف لم يترك لهم سقفا يغطيهم
اوضاع السوريين كانت سيئه لكنها اليوم
اسوا مع هذا الزلزال الذي خلف حتى الان
مقتل
1580 وفق اخر تحديث من المقصد السوري
لحقوق الانسان من جهته ناشد الدفاع المدني
السوري تقديم المساعده لانقاذ مئات
العائلات السوريه تحت الانقاض في شمال غرب
البلاد جراء هذا الزلزال المدمر هذا وظهرت
لقطات محاوله فرق الانقاذ مساعده العالقين
تحت الانقاض وتقديم المساعدات اللازمه في
بلده الاتارب في حلب الغربي بعد زلزال
المدمر نتابع
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا ينضم الى نائب مدير الدفاع
المدني السوري مدير مصطفى
متابعتك ايضا كيف تصفنا الاوضاع في شمال
غرب سوريا حتى الان
اهلا وسهلا ومرحبا بكم وبالاخوه المشاهدين
جميعا صراحه الوضع يعني كلمه كارثه هي
كلمه قليله على وصف هذا الوضع المنطقه في
شمال غربي سوريا هي منطقه تعتبر منكوبه
بالكامل لم يمر على هذه المنطقه ولا على
سوريا بالعموم يعني مثل هذا الزلزال لم
يستجب فرق الخوازل البيضاء يعني منذ
التاسيس هذه المنظمه منذ بدايه الثوره
السوريه عام 2011 لم يعني يمر عمليه انقاذ
على القوات البيضاء في هذا الحجم وبهذا
المستوى حتى الان الفرق منذ اللحظات
الاولى من وقوع هذا الزلزال متواجد للفرق
العمل الدفاع المدني يعني اعلن حاله
الاستنفار الكامل لكامل الاطقم وكامل
الاليات ووجه هذه الاليات الى اماكن العمل
من اجل تقديم المساعده للعالقين تحت
الانقاض ولكن هذه الجهود للاسف هي جهود
تحتاج الى تضافر دولي كامل حتى نستطيع ان
نخفف يعني من من هذه الكارثه على هؤلاء
السكان وعلى هؤلاء العارفين تحت الانقاض
طيب ما هي اكثر المناطق تضررا في شمال
سوريا
في الحقيقه المناطق الحدوديه القريبه من
الحدود السوريه التركيه في شمال غرب سوريا
كانت هي المناطق التي اخذت الحظ الاوفر من
عمليات الانهيار او سقوط المباني تحديدا
في منطقه جنديرس في ريف عفرين كانت مدينه
منكوبه بالكامل في منطقه حارم منطقه سلقين
منطقه بسنيه هي المناطق القريبه من منطقه
حارم ايضا هي منطقه حدوديه كمان ايضا
عماله نصيب كبير من الانهيارات والضحايا
في منطقه سرمدا الدانه ترمانين التي هي
قريبه من معبر باب الهواء كان لها ايضا
حظا وافر من هذه الهيارات وكان هناك
العديد من الاشخاص تحت الانقاض واستطعنا
انتشار للعديد من الاشخاص من تحت الانقاذ
ولكن لا زال هناك عالقين وبدانا نفقد
الوقت باكثر من 30 او 31 ساعه عمل حتى
الان يعني بدا الوقت يمر هذا الوقت ليس من
صالح هؤلاء العالقين بدانا نفقد حياه بعض
العال تحت الانقاذ بسبب صعوبه الاعداد
كبيره الاعداد العالقين كبيره هل تتواصلون
معهم
نعم نعم للاسف هناك اعداد كبيره لازال نحن
نتكلم عن اكثر من 700 موقع عمل 700 انهيار
منتشر في شمال غرب سوريا فنحن نتحدث عن
اعداد كبيره هي موجوده تحت الانقراض حاليا
نستطيع ان نسمع بعض الاصوات نحاول ان نصل
الى هذه الاصوات استطعنا انتشار اكثر من
22 مصاب من تحت الانقاذ في خلال العمل 30
ساعه الماضيه ايضا استطعنا ان ننتشر بما
يقارب 800 يعني قتيل او جثه
الماضيه لازلنا نسمع اصوات حتى الان ولكن
نحن نخشى اذا تاخر الوصول الى هذه الاصوات
ان نفقدها وان نصل الى جثث ولا نصل الى
الزمن بالتاكيد يعني الى اي مدى في
تقديراتكم هم قادرون على الصمود ظل هذه
الظروف الصعبه
الحقيقه الظروف صعبه وكما قلت نحن في سباق
حقيقي مع الزمن الظروف صعبه الظروف
انهيارات والناس تحت الانقاض بالاضافه الى
ظرف الشتاء يعني المطر لم يفارق اجواء
شمال غرب سوريا منذ اللحظات الاولى من
وقوع هذا الزلزال وحتى الان فهناك امطار
وهناك ثلوج في بعض المناطق لا هي التي
تزيد تزيد المعاناه هل هي التي تؤدي الى
بروده يعني اجساد الاشخاص الموجودين تحت
الانقاض وهذا يساهم بتقليل فرصهم للصمود
اكثر وهذا يزيد معاناتها معاناه اكبر
فلذلك كما تقول نحن في سباق حقيقي مع
الزمن نحن ناشدنا منذ اللحظات الاولى كافه
الدول العالم ان ان تصل المساعدات لفرق
القوات البيضاء الفرق الدفاع الذي شمال
غرب سوريا حتى نستطيع ان ننقذ الاحياء من
تحت هذه الانقاذ حتى هذه اللحظه للاسف لم
تصل اي مساعدات حقيقيه الى شمال غرب سوريا
يعني نستطيع ان نقول انها ساهمت بمساعده
الفرق العامله على الارض نعم نحن نتمنى
هذه المناشده شكرا لك كنت معنا النائب
مدير الدفاع المدني السوري منير مصطفى
مشاهدينا هذه صور مباشره ايضا اهمينا
عمليات الانقاذ التي يقوم بها عمال
الانقاذ عن بحثا عن ناجين بين انقاض الاف
المباني في منطقه اغازي عنتاب التركيه
التي انهارت بسبب الزلزال الذي ضرب جنوب
تركيا وشمال غرب سوريا
هناك ايضا مشاهدين ايضا صباح اليوم اعلن
مركز رصد الزلازل الاوروبي عن هزه بقوه
خمسه درجات فاصله سته على مقياس ريختر ضرب
وسط تركيا ولم ترد بعد انباء عن سقوط
المزيد من الضحايا او خسائر اعنت ايضا
مشاهدينا اداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه
من جهتها ارتفاع عدد قتل زلزال الذي ضرب
جنوبي البلاد الى ما يقارب ثلاثه الاف
قتيل الجزاء المدمر مشاهدينا الذي حفز
تركيا وسوريا
بالتاكيد هو ايضا حرك ايضا مبدا التضامن
الانساني حيث تحركت حكومات والدول لتقديم
المساعده العاجله الصين على سبيل المثال
وكما سنتابع ايضا في هذه النشره قالت
وسائل الاعلام فيها ان بكين
ستقدم دفعه اولى من المساعدات قدرها خمسه
ملايين الف دولار كمساعده طارئه لجهود
الاغاثه في تركيا بعد ازياء الكبير الذي
ضرب البلاد هذا الاسبوع ايضا الصليب
الاحمر الصيني مشاهدينا سيقدم مساعده
طارئه قيمتها 200 الف دولار لكل من تركيا
وسوريا وما زلنا معكم مشاهدينا في متابعه
هذه الصور المباشره لعمليات الانقاذ في
غاز عنتاب التركيه وعمليات البحث عن ناجين
بين الركام هذه
الانقاض
الحصيه الاجماليه لعدد القتلى حتى الان
مشاهدينا في البلدين نتحدث عن تركيا
وسوريا
تجاوزت حصيله خمسه الاف قتيل بعد هزات
ارضيه عنيفه ضربت قريبه من الحدود التركيه
السوريه بلغت قوتها سبعه درجات فاصله
ثمانيه اداره الكوارث التركيه مشاهدينا
ايضا اكدت ارتفاع عدد قتل زلزال في تركيا
الى
والجرحى ايضا الى عشرين الفا واربعمائه
وسته وعشرين جريحا
وعلى امل مساعده ناجين محاصرين تحت
الانقاض التي خلفها زلزال المدمر في تركيا
اظهر مقطع فيديو رجلا وهو يربط خيطا في
زجاجه ماء قبل ان يقوم بانزالها بين
الانقاض في مدينه هاتاي جنوب تركيا
لمساعده الناجين الذين ما زالوا محاصرين
تحت الانقاض نتابع
[موسيقى]
مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل فرار ما
لا يقل عن 20 نزيلا بينهم عناصر من داعش
من سجن في شمال غرب سوريا بعد الزلزال
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد افادت مصادر
السوريه بفرار عشرين نزيرا على الاقل من
سجن راجو شمال غرب سوريا بينهم سجناء من
تنظيم داعش وتاتي عمليه الفرار بعد تنفيذ
عصيان داخل السجن افرازال الذي ضرب مناطق
في سوريا واسفر عن تصدع جدران السجن
التابع لفصائل مواويل لتركيا في بلده راجو
قرب الحدود التركيه ويضم سجن نحو الفيسجين
ينتمي معظمهم لتنظيم داعش
[موسيقى]
وصل الرجال انقاذ دوليون الى مطار اضنه في
جنوب تركيا اليوم وذلك للمساعده في جهود
الانقاذ جراء الزلزال العنيف الذي ضرب كلا
من تركيا وسوريا ووفقا لوكاله رايتنز فان
مجموعات الانقاذ تنتمي لدول صربيا
والمانيا ورومانيا واسبانيا من اجل مساعده
في البحث عن ناجين
[موسيقى]
يؤكد استعداد منظمه الامم المتحده لدعم
جهود الاستجابه الطارئه بايضا وجهت فريقي
للتنسيق مع تركيا وتوفير المساعدات
اللازمه
بوتين مستعدون للمساعده في القضاء على
تدعيه الكارثه
فرنسا مستعده لتوفير مساعده عاجله للسكان
في تركيا وسوريا اسرائيل تعرض ارسال فرق
بحث وانقاذ وفرق طبيه الى تركيا وسوريا
المانيا تعهدت بتقديم مساعدات شامله
لضحايا الزلزال عبر كل الوسائل المتاحه
ايطاليا بدات بالفعل في تجهيز فرق الانقاذ
التي ستسافر الى تركيا
بكين تعلن استعدادها لتقديم مساعدات
انسانيه عاجله الى تركيا وسوريا
في هذا الاطار مشاهدينا اجرى الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن اتصالا هاتفيا مع نظيره
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان لتقديم التعازي
وتجديد التاكيد على استعداد واشنطن
للمساعده في جهود الانقاذ في جهود الانقاذ
بعد الزلزال وقال البيت الابيض ان الفرق
الامريكيه انتشرت بشكل سريع لدعم جهود
البحث والانقاذ التركيه هذا وقال دعنا
تونسكو رئيس وفد الاتحاد الاوروبي لدى
سوريا ان هناك حاجه لاستمرار وصول
المساعده الى المحتاجين بكل السبل عبر
الخطوط وعبر الحدود واضاف ستوريسكو ان
الوقت حان لدعم جميع السوريين المتضررين
من الكارثه في جميع مناطق سوريا مبديا
استعداد الاتحاد الاوروبي للمساعده هذا هو
اعرب كل من رئيس وزراء استراليا ونظيره
النيوزلندي عن تعازيهما لاسر وضحايا زلزال
العنيف الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا واوضح رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي انطوني البانيز ان
بلاده ستقدم مساعدات انسانيه اوليه بقيمه
10 ملايين دولار بالتعاون مع الهلال
الاحمر والصليب الاحمر
هل يمكنني ان اعرب عن عمق تعاطف استراليا
وتعازيها للاسر والمجتمعات التي فقدت
احبائها لقد راينا الاف القتلى وعشرات
الالاف من الجرحى خلال هذه الماساه هذه
الزلازل المتعدده التي ضربت المنطقه لها
تاثير مدمر واليوم يمكنني ان اعلن ان
الحكومه الاستراليه ستقدم مساعدات انسانيه
اوليه بقيمه عشره ملايين دولار للمتضررين
وذلك من خلال شركائنا في الصليب الاحمر
والهلال الاحمر ومن خلال الوكالات
الانسانيه من جهته نقل رئيس الوزراء
نيوزلندي
بلاده الاسري الضحايا من الشعبين التركي
والسوري واضحا ان وزير الشؤون الخارجيه في
بلاده سيقوم باصدار تفاصيل مليون ونصف
مليون دولار التي ستساهم بها نيوزيلندا
للحد من تداعيات الزلزال العنيف هذا هل
يمكنني ان انقل مشاعر حزن واضيف الى هذا
تعازي شعب نيوزيلندا لاولئك الموجودين في
تركيا وسوريا نحن نعرف القليل عن الزلازل
في نيوزيلندا لذا قلوبنا معكم ستساهم
نيوزيلندا في الجهد الدولي وسيقوم وزير
الشؤون الخارجيه في نيوزيلندا باصدار
تفاصيل مليون ونصف المليون دولار التي
سنساهم بها
من جهتها قالت وسائل الاعلام الصينيه ان
بكين ستقدم دفعه اولى قدرها خمسه ملايين
بعد زلزال الكبير الذي ضرب البلاد هذا
الاسبوع واضافت ان الصليب الاحمر الصيني
سيقدم مساعده طارئه قيمتها 200 الف دولار
لكل من تركيا وسوريا هذا واهادت وكاله
الانباء السعوديه بان ولي العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان قدم التعازي هاتفيا
لرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان في ضحايا
زلزال واكد امير محمد بن سلمان وقوف
السعوديه ومساندتها لتركيا لتجاوز هذه
الكارثه الطبيعيه بدوره اعرب اردوغان عن
تقديره لوقوف السعوديه الى جانب تركيا في
هذا الظرف الصعب
مشاهدينا اسطنبول ينضم الينا الكاتب
الصحفي فراس رضوان اوغلو اهلا بك سيد فراس
معنا في هذه النشره
الكارثه التي تمر بها تركيا الان لم تكن
متوقع بطبيعه الحال لكن كيف يمكن التقييم
جهود الاغاثه المبذوله حتى الان
والعمليات التي تقوم بها العمليه الحكومه
التركيه هل نجحت بشكل او باخر في تحجين
تداعيات هذه الكارثه
يعني الحقيقه الكارثه كارثه يعني مهما
قامت الحكومه او حتى فرق الانقاذ بما يمكن
ان تقوم به تبقى الحقيقه
النتائج كبيره جدا من الناحيه السلبيه او
الكارثيه عدد
الضحايا
3371 والجرحى عشرون
الفنى التي مهدمه وهذه المعدمه التي اعلن
عنها يعني لم يذكر حتى البناء التي تاثرت
بالاهتزازات الارتداديه قبل
575 هذه ارقام حقيقه ضخمه جدا على عشر مدن
لكن الحقيقه لم يتوقف احد لم نسمع ان احدا
توقف او نام او حتى تراخ في العمل بشكل او
باخر لذلك اظن ان كل للكل قام بعمله بشكل
كبير حتى الجيش اعلن انه قام
ب154 طلع جويه لنقل معدات وسيارات وعربات
نقل الى المناطق بسبب ان الطرقات تقريبا
بعضها مغلق وبعضها لا يعمل بشكل جيد ونقل
عربات ربما اللوجستيه وطبيه وغيرها لكن
الكارثه حقيقه اكبر مما الاستيعاب لكن
الان اظن بعد وصول الفرق الانقاذ كثيره
يعني التي وصلت منها بدا العمل حقيقه
جورجيا ولبنان ايضا الطلائع والدول التي
وصلت يعني اظن هذا يساعد كثير في تسريع
عمليات الانقاذ انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه يعني
قبل قليل كنت اقرا خبرا جميلا عن انقاذ
يعني ام وطفلها البيبي صغير جدا يعني
فكان يعني هذا شعور جميل لذلك
بالامل لكن سيد نعم اخر زلزال ضربه تركي
ربما كان قبل
ربع قرض تقريبا من الزمان هل استفادت
تركيا من هذه التجربه القاسيه في الماضي
وهل استعدت لي
يعني ساكون اكثر منطقيا في في يعني تخليص
الاحداث تركيا دوله على منطقه زلزاليه
وذلك الاستعدادات بشكل كبير وقوي جدا لكن
كنا نعلم ان الاستادات تاتي مدينه او
مدينتين قرب ليس اكثر هذه المره نحن نتكلم
عن 10 مدن او عشر الولايات مدنها وريفها
وقراها انا لا اظن ان كانت القدره يعني
تستطيع ان تستوعب هذا الحجم
تقريبا
[موسيقى]
يعني نحن نتكلم على رقم كبير جدا لان انا
لا اظن ان كان هناك استعداد لهذا الرقم
الكبير ولذلك منذ البدايه اعلن سليمان
لانه رفع الحاله الى الدرج الرابع وطلب
المساعده مباشره تمت الاتصالات عبر وزاره
الخارجيه عبر الافاد وعبر الهلال الاحمر
الذي تواصل ايضا مع نظرائه في دول العالم
لذلك انا اظن ان الاستعدادات لم تكن الى
عشر المدن رب كما هو كان سابقا مدينه
مدينتين في هذا الاحتياط ولذلك لاحظنا
قدوم مساعدات من جميع مدون التركيه لكنها
يعني ستتاخر مهما كان سرعتها بسبب الاوضاع
السيئه التي ذكرتها في قناتكم
في مثل هذه الظروف على الجميع بالطبع ان
يتناسى ويتسامع عن خلافات السياسيه ويركز
على انقاذ حياه الناس هل هكذا هو الوضع
الان في تركيا ام ان هناك دعنا نقول من
يحاول الصيد في الماء العكر
بالنسبه للسياسيين هكذا نعم يعني في الامس
السيد
الرئيس والمرشح الاخر ربما للرئاسه
القادمه مع الرئيس اردوغان ذهب هو السيد
كمال
ونائب الرئيس الى زياره رئيس
يعني هذا واضح الرساله اليوم رئيس الحركه
القوميه ايضا اعرب عن تضامنين مع الجميع
والى اخره في الامس كان هناك خبر ارسلته
ربما الداخليه بين هناك ثلاثه عشر موقعا
مزيفا يبث اخبارا غير صحيحه لا اعلم يعني
من سميت او التحريض في في تلك النقاط يعني
هناك من يحاول ان يلعب لكن انا لا اظن
السياسيون داخلون في هذه القضيه ربما هي
فقط من اجل الشهره او من اجل يعني اغراض
اعلانيه اعلاميه لكنها ضئيله جدا مقارنه
في الصراعات السياسيه الداخليه في تركيا
اذا اظن ان الرساله وصلت للسيد كم
بين زلزال امس وزلزال عام 99
[موسيقى]
لم يؤثر يعني على ضحايا ولكنه كان عالي
وصل الى سبعه فاصله واحده واثنين لا اذكر
تماما
لكن هذا الزلزال
شمل ولايات
اشهر ولايات في عام كانت في منطقه ازميت
وكوجالي
قرب اسطنبوليا حتى اسطنبول لم تتاثر في
ذلك الوقت لكن
كانت في ازميل السقوط الكبير
للضحايا والابنيه ولذلك يعني كان رغم عدد
قتلها الكبير جدا لكنه كان يعني محدود في
منطقه معينه هذا اقل ربما عددا
للقتله ولكن المساحه واسعه جدا وضرب
دولتين يعني ايضا نعزي في سوريا ايضا نفس
الشيء الاعداد الكبيره هناك والمساحه
الكبيره هناك طيب اسمح لي بالتنوين هذا
الخبر العاجل نقل عن الصحه العالميه تقول
ان هناك صعوبه في وصول مستلزمات الطبيه
الى سوريا وتركيا هل ينطبق هذا ايضا على
المناطق التي تتابع الاخبار فيها سيد فراس
يعني هل تقطعت طرق لهذه الدرجه
والمستلزمات الطبيه هناك صعوبه كبيره في
ايصالها الى مستحقها
يعني انا اظن في بسوريا ممكن هذا الامر
بسبب يعني المشاكل الميدانيه هناك في
تركيا بعض المناطق ما زالت الامور صعبه
حتى الان لان تلك المناطق في بعضها يعني
تلاليه وجبانيه وايضا تقطعت الطرق والثلوج
ربما هذه اثرت في الامس تكلم السيد اقطع
حول منطقه عثمانيه ومنطقه ملاطيا فيها
الطرقات جدا متقاطعه اظنهم ايضا يذكرونها
المطارات يعني المطار في
انطاكيا او هاتاي مطار في عنتاب ربما حتى
الان لم يفتحها بسبب تدمر تدمير او خروجه
عن الخدمه للمتراجين هناك
حتى انطاكيا يعني هناك صريح كثيره جاءت
تقريبا المدينه كلها مدمره هناك ابنيه
وقعت وابنيه حتى في عجاله كانت رئيسه
بلديه
غازي عنتاب تكلمت عن احدى الكره التي قالت
ان سكانها 60 الف نصفهم غير موجودين يعني
يعني تعابير حقيقه قاسيه طبعا
تحتاج جهود اكثر قادمه ننتظر ايضا لدي
الساعات القادمه طيب
الادلبي اهلا بك سيدي ابراهيم معنا في هذه
النشره ولو تنقل لنا ايضا مشاهداتكم
ومتابعتك لاوضاع الناس في ادلب وفي
المناطق المتضرره بصوره عامه في الشمال
الغربي من سوريا
دعني ابدا بالاحصائيات
التقريبيه بالنسبه لاعداد الضحايا واعداد
الابنيه المتدمره التي خلفها الزلزالان
والرداد الاهتزازيه بالتزامن مع عمليات
البحث عن ناجين تحت انقاذ التي تقوم بها
فرق الدفاع المدني والمتطوع المتطوعين
المدنيين برفقه المنظمات الانسانيه وصل
العدد الى 770 شخص حتى هذه اللحظه ممن سجل
قد لقوا حذفهم جراء عمليات الانهيار
انهيار المنازل فوق القاطنيه اضافه الى ان
هناك
210 مباني كانت قد دمرت بشكل كامل على
قاطنيها
التضرر بشكل جزئي كان هناك 520 مبنى كان
قد تضرر بشكل جزئي منذ بدايه الزلزال
الاول في الصباح الامس حتى حتى هذه
الساعات طبعا هذه الاحصائيات هي احصائيات
تقريبيه الارقام هي اكثر من ذلك ولكن هذا
ما تمكنت فرق الدفاع المدني والشبكات
المنتشره في عمليات الانقاذ والبحث من
تاكيده وتوثيقه اعداد المصابين تجاوزت
2200 مصاب ممن تم نقلهم وتلقي العلاج في
النقاط الطبيه والمشافي
والمشافي المركزيه وايضا الميدانيه تحدث
عن المشفى العسكري في عفرين الذي منذ
منتصف الامس كان قد اعلن انه يعمل فوق
طاقته الاستيعابيه ايضا للكادر الطبي
المستشفى عقربات بريف ادلب مستشفى باب
الهوى بالقرب من الحدود السوريه التركيه
والنقاط الطبيه التي كانت منتشره وجبت
تنبيه الى ان هناك العديد من المباني
المهتريه الان او المتصدعه جراء الهزات
الارتداديه في الشمال الغربي من سوريا
المناشدات التي صدعت فيها التي صدحت
البارحه من قبل الدفاع المدني والمنظمات
من اجل خروج من المناطق السكنيه باتجاه
العراء او باتجاه الاراضي الزراعيه
لمحاوله الحفاظ على سلامتهم على حياتهم
كانوا قد قضوا ليله بارده حتى الساعات
الصباح المبكر في العطاء طيب سيدي ابراهيم
يعني عمليات الانقاذ التي تقوم بها هذه
الفرق الميدانيه من دفاع مدني وغيره في
الشمال السوري او شمال غرب سوريا كيف يمكن
تقييمها وتوصيفها مع الحديث عن نقص كبير
في المعدات وفي الخبرات ايضا
لنبدا عن عمليه الابلاغ الدفاع المدني
يتلقى البلاغات من الشهود العيان من الذين
شهدوا انهيار المباني وهم متاكدين من وجود
اناس داخل او كانوا داخل هذه المباني
نائمين لم تسمح لهم الفرصه للمغادره قبل
انهيار هذه المنازل اتحدث عن المدن
الرئيسيه بدايه بالاتارب التي تبعد عن
الحدود السوريه التركيه اكثر من عشرين
كيلو متر هذه المدينه كان لها النصيب
الاكبر من اعداد قتلى المدني الدفاع
المدني توجه بعدد من الياته باتجاه تلك
المنطقه اي ريف حلب الغربي من اجل مساعده
الع تحت الانقاذ بالحديد الادوات التي
يستخدمها الدفاع المدني كانت يمتلك عددا
من سيارات النقل اضافه لسيارات الاسعاف
وما يعرف من اجل عمليه ازاله الانقاذ ولكن
هذه المعدات التي يمتلكها الدفاع المدني
يضمن مراكزها المنتشره في شمال غرب سوريا
لم تكن كافيه
لانتشال الناجين او العالقين تحت الانقاذ
مما دعا الحكومه السوريه مؤقته والجهات
المعنيه التي تمتلك الاليات من اجل
تزويدها للمتطوعين وفرق الدفاع المدني
ساهمت في عمليه فتح الطرق للوصول الى بعض
المناطق الاكثر تضررا هناك مناطق انا هناك
مناطق لم تدخلها على اليات ولا حتى
متطوعين بازاله الانقاب اقتصرت فقط على
جهود فرديه لاقارب او ذوي الضحايا في
المناطق التي تبعد اكثر من 30 كم عن حدود
السوريه التركيه وذلك بسبب صعوبه الوصول
الها بسبب انقطاع الطرق العاصفه الثلجيه
التي كانت بدات منذ يومين ثم تلها عاصفه
مطريه الظروف الجويه لا تساعد بعمليه
انتشال او عمل الدفاع المدني والفرق
المتطوعه
المتطوعون لا يملكون الاليات والخبرات
لذلك اقتصر عملهم على محاوله ازاله
الانقاذ بالادوات البسيطه كالمغراف وغيرهم
الادوات المستخدمه سابقا في عمليه الزراعه
او حتى في عمليه الحفر الدفاع الاليات
اتحدث عن بين الحديث عن الاليات والتحدي
الذي يواجهونه في هذه الساعات او الساعات
القادمه هي نفاذ ماده الديزل من عدد من
الاليات ان كان اليات الدفاع المدني او
حتى الاليات التي كان يستخدمها المدنيون
بعمليات نقل المصابين الذين يتم استخراجهم
من تحت طيب قاسم ابراهيم يعني اضع
المقاطعه لكن عطفا على هذه المعلومات التي
اشرت اليها هناك مساعدات كبيره وصلت الى
مطار دمشق نتحدث عن مساعدات ايرانيه
ومساعدات عراقيه هل تتوقعون ان تصل بعض من
هذه المساعدات الى مناطقكم
الكثير من المساعدات لم تصل في وقت سابق
الى مخيم الركبان وكانت الامم المتحده هي
التي ارسلتها بالتحديد الى مخيم الركبان
الواقع على الحدود السوريه العراقيه
النظام الايرانيه المتمركزه على الطرق
الواصله باتجاهات المخيم او حتى في هذه
الكارثه باتجاه المناطق الشماليه لن تسمح
وسيكون هناك نوع من الضغط السياسي
والمحاربه في لقمه العيش والبقاء بالنسبه
للمدنيين وهذا ما اكدته خطابات حكومه دمشق
حيث انها لم تنوه او تعطف على ان هناك
كارثه في شمال غرب سوريا اقتصر بيانها
ولجانها على الحديث على مركز مدينه حلب
اقتصر حديثها على محافظه اللاذقيه في
الامم المتحده قال اليوم ان هذه مساعده
التي ستصل الى سوريا ستوزع على جميع
السوريين
هذا نعم رايت رايت هذا الخبر ان مساء
الامس عندما تحدث ان انه اشترط اذا كان
هناك مساعدات يجب ان تكون عبره دمشق وهذا
نوع من انواع الضغط على اليه اليه ادخال
المساعدات عبره الحدود المدنيين في شمال
غرب سوريا لا يسوقون بالنظام من خلال
تجاربهم السابقه لن اغوص بالحديث بالوضع
السياسي لان الكارثه الانسانيه هي ارقى
واعلى من الحديث على السياسه
سننتقل الى مؤتمر صحفي لنائب الرئيس
التركي فؤاد الطيب
نقوم باستخدامها في هذه المناطق من اجل
العمل على ازاله الانقاض
خاصه في الليل
احتجنا ايضا الى الرافعات
تم
توفير العديد من الرافعات بشكل جيد في هذه
المناطق ايضا اكثر من 500 رافعه تم
تخصيصها من اجل ازاله هذه الانقاض
بالاضافه الى ذلك
هناك ايضا
بامكاننا ايضا استخدام
وسائل النقل الجوي ايضا اعتبارا من صباح
هذا اليوم
سته من الطائرات وكذلك
هناك تسعه عشر من
طائرات الاسعاف الخاصه بوزاره الصحه
وهناك 135 من الطائرات التي تحمل المياه
هناك
26 من المروحيات بخاصه المروحيات عليها ان
تتوخل الحذر بسبب الظروف الجويه
وهناك ايضا
مطار اضنه تم تحويله الى مطار اللوجستي من
اجل الدعم اللوجستيه لكافه هذه المناطق من
اجل ايصال هذه المساعدات
وفرق الانقاذ عبر الجو في هاتاي وفي
كهرمان مرعش وفي قضيه مان وفي ملاطيه نقوم
بنقل فرق الانقاذ عبر الجو الى هذه
الولايات
والعمليات عمليه الانقاذ مستمره وخاصه
بتحسن الظروف الجويه نعم
في صباح هذا اليوم
وان استمر الامر على هذا المنوال فان
الناس سوف نزيد ايضا من نقل عبر الجو
ايضا هناك نقل عبر
البر تم
نقله العديد من فرق الانقاذ ومواد
المساعدات وغير ذلك
هناك اكثر من ثلاثه الاف شخص وصله من
الدول الاخرى من خارج تركيا
من اجل دعم من في هذه المساعدات وفرق
الانقاذ
كما اشرت بانه يتم نقلهم من اضنه الى هذه
الولايات المتعرضه
وبولندا والهند
المجر المانيا وسلوفاكيا وقطر
وانجلترا وروسيا وغيرها من هذه الدول نشكر
هذه الدول على دعمها لنا في هذه الكارثه
على وقوفهم الى جانبنا في
عمليات الانقاذ اكثر من 3200 شخص ايضا
انضموا اليهم كما ذكرت
هناك ايضا ايضا الكلاب التي يتم استخدامها
من اجل عمليه الانقاذ كما اشرت ايضا الى
العاملون في المجال الصحي اكثر من 4000
شخص تم تخصيصهم ايضا
هناك مستشفيات كبيره يتم نقل الجرحى اليها
واستخدامها
لاجل مداوات هؤلاء الجرحى وفتح الطرق
المؤدي الى هذه المستشفيات امر مهم ايضا
قمنا بهذا العمل على اكمل وجه هناك ايضا
مستشفيات ميدانيه متوفره في كافه هذه
المناطق وتستكمله خدماتها الصحيه فيما
يتعلق
بالطرق والمواصلات بشكل عام قبل ذلك اود
ان انتقل الى قسم السكن
والايواء هناك
الخيام التي تقام وكذلك البطانيات التي
توفر
للمتضررين من الزلازل هذه جاءت من
مناطق الدعم اللوجستيه الخاص
برئاسه افاد
وكذلك
المساعدات الانسانيه التي جاءت من جهه
الاخرى خاصه في الليل كما تعلمون
هناك
ظروف الجويه
والبرد القارس
يؤثر بشكل كبير ولكن نحن قد قمنا
باخذ الاحتياطات اللازمه كما اشرت اعتبار
من صباح هذا اليوم فاننا ننقل هذه
المستلزمات
والمساعدات عبر الجو
كذلك
الجامعات يتم استخدامها من اجل ايواء
المتضررين ايضا وكذلك المدارس التابعه
لوزاره
التعليم
تم فتح ابواب هذه المدارس من اجل استقبال
او ايواء المتضررين
شخص من وزاره التعليم وكذلك من وزاره
الرياضه
79 الف شخص جاؤوا من اجله الدعم هذه
العمليات عمليات الانقاذ
وكذلك مواد الغذائيه يتم تقديمها اليهم
وتوفيرها بشكل كامل
كما اشرت سابقا فيما يتعلق بالمواصلات
والطرق فان
طريق حطاي وريحان قد اغلق كما اشرت ولكن
تم فتح طريق
موازن له من اجل توفير هذه المواصلات الى
ايضا
خاصه فيما يتعلق
بفرق الانقاذ
يمكنهم الاستخدام هذا الطريق بشكل
مستمر
هناك ايضا طرق اخرى
مؤديه الى كهرمان مرعش تم فتحها من اجل
سرعه ايصال المساعدات
وبعض الطرق تعرضت للمشاكل بسبب هذا
الزلزال ولكن تم فتح طرق موازيه اخرى
اود ان اذكر بامر اخر
وخاصه في منطقه الكوارث فان المواصلات
مهمه جدا علينا ان ننتبه لهذا الموضوع
علينا ان نكون
واعين بهذا الخصوص لكي استمر فرق الانقاذ
بعملهم على اكمل وجه علينا ان نستخدم مثل
هذه الطرق العام المؤديه خاصه للمستشفيات
ولمناطق الكوارث على المواطنين ان لا
يستخدموا هذه الطرق
وان لا يذهبوا الى تلك المناطق
اود ان انبه المواطنين مره اخرى الى هذا
الخصوص المهم
علينا ان نترك هذا الامر
المختصين
الفرق الانقاذ وكذلك
لاولئك الذين ينقلون
المساعدات والمواد الغذائيه
علينا ان نكون واعينا بهذا الخصوص
خاصه في الطرق المؤدي الى هاتاي وكهرباء
في خلال 48 الساعه
الماضيه
تم فتح طرق
ونحن نسمح لكافه السيارات
توصل المساعدات وكذلك فرق الانقاذ ما عدا
ذلك فنحن لا نسمح بدخولهم حتى لا يعطلوا
هذا المجال
وعلى المواطنين ان يعوا هذا الامر
وفي كهرمان مرعش وفي
قضيه مان
سوف يتم فتح طرق اخرى موازيه ايضا في حال
الحاجه ولكن رساله في هذا الخصوص على
المواطنين ان يكونوا واعين في هذا الخصوص
لان المواصلات مهمه جدا وامر حياتي
فيما يتعلق بقضيه الكهرباء كما اشرت
بالامس
تم توفير ايضا
الطاقه والكهرباء الى منطقه عثمانيه
كما اشرت باننا سوف نوصل ايضا الكهرباء
الى هاتاي والريحان
في هذا اليوم سوف يتم ايصال الكهرباء ايضا
في ملاطيا
يمكننا ايضا ان نصل الكهرباء الى كامله
كما تعلمون نحن نقوم بايصال الكهرباء الى
المناطق المتعرضه والمتضرره بشكل مراقب
تماما
ويتم ايصال الكهرباء الى المناطق بموافقه
من رئاسه افاد لاداره الكوارث حتى لا يكون
هناك خطوره بالنسبه لمن هم تحت الانقاض
في كهرمان مرعش هناك كهرباء ايضا تم ايصال
الكهرباء الى مركز
ولكن
الى الان لا يتم ايصال الكهرباء اليه
بسبب استمراريه الخطوره فيما يتعلق ايضا
بالغاز الطبيعي هناك مشاكل
لهذا مؤتمر الصحفي نائب الرئيس التركي
فؤاد الذي قال ان المدارس والجامعات تحولت
الى مراكز ايواء وفرق انقاذ من اربعه عشره
دوله وصلت وبدات العمل واخرى من سبعين
دوله تصل لاحقا وقارئين مطار اضنه تحول
الى مطار لنقل المساعده اللوجستيه للمناطق
المنكوبه مشاهدينا بهذا القدر ونشكر ايضا
وابراهيم الادلبي اذا مشاهدينا والدتها هي
اول من خطر ببالها بعدما تم انقاذها من
تحت الانقاذ التي انهارت على جسدها الصغير
اين امي هكذا تسال طفله صغيره في مدينه
هاتايا التركيه جراء الزلزال المدمر الذي
ضرب البلاد
خلينا الصاله ده
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا هذه مشاهد جديده لحجم الدمار في
بلدتي جندريس في عفرين اقصى غرب الشمال
السوري في حيث انهار اربع وثمانون مبدا
على رؤوس ساكلها وفق مراسل العربيه وذلك
جراء زلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا الاثنين
بقوه سبع درجات فاصله ثمانيه على مقياس
[موسيقى]